[Music]
this morning in our pushing-the-limit
series one man is taking his piano
skills to the edges of cliffs in the
middle of deserts less than 10 percent
of Americans attend classical music
concerts a year
Hunter Nowak is trying to change that
and so he's transforming the entire
concert experience starting with finding
the perfect backdrop Jan Crawford
recently met up with him Jan good
morning well good morning so you know no
I grew up I mean Heike fishing hunting
there in Oregon and he left to follow
his dreams he did plastico music
training here and overseas but he
decided to come back to where he came
from he left behind the brand concert
halls for the Grand outdoors and taking
what he loves to the place he calls home
[Music]
is a place of spectacular beauty cliffs
tall trees of northern Oregon and then
the unexpected
floating through the air the elegant
melody of classical music my mom and I
were saying wouldn't it be cool if if
you could just have a piano and go
anywhere so that's what hunter Nowak did
traveling across the Pacific Northwest
introducing classical music to new
audiences in some wild places I could do
a show pretty much every day I'd be
happy he chose his piano all over this
state on a flatbed trailer it's really
kind of an audacious thing that you're
doing do people go what yeah what are
you doing it's really impressive to have
a nine-foot Steinway being hauled around
with the pickup truck with the help of a
few friends flatbed becomes a stage I
wanted the same piano that is in
Carnegie Hall and it's in all of the
mattresses this is the same instrument
and in a way I feel like it it fits
because then these are our halls the
Columbia Gorge is our Cathedral and the
outboard desert is our church on this
night it's on a cliff jetting into the
Columbia River because it seemed
different playing here it does I mean
there are more distractions but manned
with force but you know I love to just
be able to close my eyes or between
pieces take a breath in fresh air maybe
you affect
[Music]
Nowak performs in the landscape spaces
with astounding natural beauty and rich
history you're taking this like
beautiful music to places where people
would not have access to it yeah you
know we have the people that come from
Portland and Eugene that are classical
music lovers that get to explore these
parts of the state that they otherwise
might not and then we have people that
are coming to these places that are
familiar to them the places they go
fishing places they go camping it gives
people sort of a different lens through
which to see this land that they know
and love he makes the surroundings part
of the performance this land is owned by
the Native American Warm Springs tribe
and joining Nowak here is James Edmund
Greely in this reimagined concert hall
Nowak hopes to remove the normal
barriers to classical music
there are free tickets casual clothes
and the opposite of formal seating like
perching on a rock overlooking the stage
a third of his audience has never
attended a classical music concert but
even those who have likely haven't done
it like this wearing wireless headphones
to encourage wandering with the music in
your headphones the music becomes a
soundtrack to your experience in the
landscape
Nowak is winning over the classical
skeptics I said to my friend if she had
invited me to a classical music concert
I would have said but this was
tremendous and the outdoor averse well
she was a little bit hesitant at first I
am speechless very speechless there was
nothing artificial here it was all
natural natural surroundings yes indeed
it's a new community Nowak hopes to
create each night on the edge of nowhere
what do you hope they get out of it I
hope that they find little moments of
magic it's those little moments that
draw people's emotions that like give
them space to feel something and to
notice the beauty around us and even for
an hour wander wherever they want is
something totally worth doing and
they're finding that magical moment with
people that they may think they have
nothing in common with absolutely
[Music]
now Nowak wants to make sure anyone can
go to these concerts especially to the
people who live around all those places
where he's performing so there are
always some free tickets and he's
considering taking this outside his home
state for concerts in the wild all over
the country gale boy Jan beautifully
done I feel better already just
listening to him what a given be sharing
with all of us I know I was so soothing
yeah lucky for him I almost walked out
of the studio externship getting here
that was really nice Thank You hunter I
love the woman had said yes indeed he's
right